>> Jimmy: PERFORMING "WELCOME
TO MY ISLAND" FROM HER ALBUM
"DESIRE, I WANT TO TURN INTO
YOU," GIVE IT UP FOR
CAROLINE POLACHEK!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
♪ WELCOME TO MY ISLAND
SEE THE PALM TREES
WAVE IN THE WIND
WELCOME TO MY ISLAND ♪
♪ HOPE YOU LIKE ME
YOU AIN'T LEAVING
WELCOME TO MY ISLAND
SEE THE PALM TREES ♪
♪ WAVE IN THE WIND
WELCOME TO MY ISLAND
HOPE YOU LIKE ME
YOU AIN'T LEAVING ♪
♪ DESIRE
I WANNA TURN INTO YOU
DESIRE
I WANNA TURN INTO YOU ♪
♪ FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE
FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE ♪
♪♪
♪ WELCOME TO MY ISLAND
SEE THE PALM TREES
WAVE IN THE WIND
WELCOME TO MY ISLAND ♪
♪ HOPE YOU LIKE ME
YOU AIN'T LEAVING
DESIRE
I WANNA TURN INTO YOU ♪
♪ DESIRE
I WANNA TURN INTO YOU
FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE ♪
♪ FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE
I AM MY FATHER'S
DAUGHTER IN THE END ♪
♪ HE SAYS WATCH YOUR EGO
WATCH YOUR HEAD GIRL
YOU'RE SO SMART
SO TALENTED ♪
♪ BUT NOW THE WATER'S
TURNING RED
AND IT'S ALL YOUR FAULT
AND IT'S ALL YOUR MESS ♪
♪ AND YOU'RE ALL ALONE
IF YOU GO TO BED TOO
HIGH ON YOUR ADRENALINE
YOU GOTTA GO SOMEWHERE ♪
♪ WHERE YOU CAN'T PRETEND GO
FORGET THE RULES
AND FORGET YOUR FRIENDS
JUST YOU AND ♪
♪ YOUR REFLECTION
CAUSE NOTHING'S GONNA
BE THE SAME AGAIN
NO NOTHING'S GONNA ♪
♪ BE THE SAME AGAIN
♪ DESIRE
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
♪ FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE
FLOAT ON
THE OCEAN BLUE ♪
♪ HEY HEY HEY HEY
HEY HEY HEY HEY ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]